[Music]  don't friend sitting next yeah Simon  Cowell's been known to launch singing  careers but candy jumpstart his  four-year-old son Eric's dating life  you are hilarious I want you to date my  son it all started when five year old  singer little Sophie Grace the America's  Got Talent stage for her first audition  and now she is apparently smin sheepish  makes my heart mount but when the five  year old singer returned for judges cuts  Eric was put on the spot by his famous  dad somebody has a bit of a crush on you  my son Eric  [Music]  he shot still that didn't stop Sophie  from serving up a show-stopping Frank  Sinatra cover  [Music]  sadly it wasn't enough to move the tiny  Beltre to the live shows but maybe  there's still a future with Simon's son  oh my god he's not happy boys will be  boys  [Music]